Hi.
My name is Michal Gala.
And I am a junior in
chemical engineering,
doing research in
[INAUDIBLE] theorem group
on electrochemical
ammonia production.
The reason for this is
important because ammonia
goes into all agricultural
production in the world in the
from of fertilizer.
It has fueled the steady
growth of a world population
over the last 100 years.
But the method we currently
have available of producing
it has a very large
capital cost, upwards
of a billion dollars
per a single plant,
and carries a proportional
penalty, in terms of,
CO2 emissions.
This is why we are
trying to utilize
lithium's natural reactivity
towards gaseous nitrogen
to produce ammonia at ambient
temperature and pressure
with oxygen as the only
byproduct of a reaction.
We do so by producing lithium
nitride from metallic lithium
and nitrogen, and
then hydrolyzing
this compound forming ammonia,
which has been released
and quantified, and
lithium ions, which
are then electrochemically
re-plated as lithium metal.
This process requires a hydrogen
carrier, so a product source.
And this is where
my project comes in.
I am looking at
different compounds that
can be used for that
purpose and trying
to find trends between them.
We identified three
groups of compounds.
Some of them are active in the
process and produce ammonia
as is expected and reported
in previous literature.
But some of them do not do that.
We divided them
into two categories
for inactive and the
hyperactive sources.
Inactive sources,
in some way, do not
seem to activate
lithium towards reaction
with nitrogen, so the
nitridation reaction,
and do not give any yield
of ammonia produced.
And we are now doing
research trying
to explain why that
is because it's
a very surprising
result because lithium
reacts with nitrogen by itself.
It shouldn't need to be
activated towards that.
Another interesting
result we got
is the specific characteristics
of an active [INAUDIBLE]
sources.
And it turns out
that some of them
are not exactly the same as
reported literature, which
means that very small structural
changes to the molecules
cause a big difference in
their reactivity in the system.
Doing that allowed us to
optimize the ammonia production
as a function of concentration
and choice of [INAUDIBLE]
source leading to
significant improvements
in faradaic efficiencies
of produced ammonia using,
especially, [INAUDIBLE] source.
Thank you.